this morning in our series school
matters we're learning about a new
program
that aims to connect students and
teachers after a year of remote learning
isn't everybody tired of that
yeah they are a long was created by the
chan zuckerberg initiative
co-founded by dr priscilla chan and her
husband facebook's mark zuckerberg and
gradient learning
where dr chan serves on the board so
this is an
online platform that allows teachers to
ask students probing questions about
themselves and their lives
outside of the classroom but the hope is
to build more meaningful relationships
inside the classroom along officially
launches today
is available for free to teachers around
the country right now
dr chan joins us first on cbs this
morning there she is
hey priscilla very good to see you
bright and early this morning
so let's get started about the app good
morning to you
i know that this has been tough for
teachers i know it's been tough for
students
were you hearing something from both of
those groups that made you think we need
to do something
yeah at the beginning of the pandemic we
had a call to action
for us long standing at the chan
zuckerberg initiative
we've always known that supporting the
whole child is critical and for us that
means actually supporting their
well-being
and their academic development a huge
part of that
is the student-teacher relationship that
was challenging for schools pre-pandemic
but even harder in remote learning
at the beginning of the pandemic we
heard teachers asking for help because
it was harder than
ever to engage and motivate students so
we work closely with
researchers teachers software developers
and students
to build a tool that can help
supercharge that critical
student-teacher relationship
so now we have along a digital
reflection tool that makes it easier
for teachers to connect one-on-one with
their students and get beyond that
frustrating
one-word answer that many teachers and
parents are used to
so what do they do exactly for six
months priscilla what do they do exactly
when it says ask questions like what
type of questions are you talking about
so the great thing is the questions are
all research based
and so that it's been studied
on how to actually get to the core of
the
student mentor relationship and then
this student gets that prompt
and on their own time in a way that they
feel comfortable with
they pass back a reflection so you might
get a question like
what's something you're proud of what's
a current challenge you're facing
and then the student can really think
about it in their own space and time
and pass back a video audio or text to
their teacher
so that the teacher can see that full
view of the child's life
i get it so you have to have don't you
think you have to have one-on-one
um interaction with the students and the
teachers in order
to grow really when you're learning
academically so it allows the one-on-one
connection is what you're saying
yeah i mean kids don't learn in a vacuum
they're bringing in
that everything that's happening in
their life and honestly in the past year
kids have gone through so much
disruption in their daily lives the way
they live
family are facing financial insecurity
they might have lost loved ones we can't
ignore that and say
come back and focus on your reading and
writing
that's not realistic and so if we
actually bring kids into the classroom
and at least figuratively say take your
mask off
we welcome you back then we have an
opportunity for them to really engage
in learning and it's that one-on-one
feeling seen and feeling like
they can raise up their voice inside and
outside of the classroom
um and um and that's going to fuel their
academic
um growth as well priscilla it's anthony
is is this meant to is sort of i mean
obviously kids are going back to school
now in many cases they've been back for
a while
in face-to-face learning is is this
meant to extend that face-to-face
relationship
outside of the classroom and essentially
give them
almost like another parental
relationship
we want it to be a mentorship which is
actually quite research-based
we know that with a mentor um
at-risk kids are 55 percent more likely
to go to college
and it's meant to make sure that a kid
feels
seen and so it's meant to actually
probe at building a very um
supportive relationship and right now
honestly it's meant to fit into a busy
school day because it's asynchronous you
don't have to
carve out time out of what's already a
packed school day for a lot of kids who
are returning to school
and so it's meant to be that supplement
that does extend beyond the school day
well i know you've got two little ones
at home so you know what it's like to be
homeschooling at this particular time
it'll be nice just to say mask off
really good to see you priscilla chan
thank you so much for joining us this
morning
thank you